this video was voted for by patrons of
questions for science
homo sapien and canis familiaris or more
simply human and dog
we're both mammals we're both omnivores
and we get along really well
though a lot of our physiology is
similar there are some major differences
one difference that is the least obvious
is our digestive systems
food goes in nutrients get absorbed and
waste comes out you wouldn't think this
process
is that much different but evolution
being evolution makes differences
for species to thrive the first part of
the digestive system
is the mouth the purpose of the mouth is
the physical breakdown of food from
large pieces into small pieces by the
action of chewing
dogs have 42 teeth in their mouth
whereas humans have 32
dogs are closely related to wolves who
evolved as carnivores
which means they subsisted on hunting
their prey or eating the remains of prey
that was already hunted
their teeth are pointier leaner and
sharper to puncture cut and tear
raw animal tissue in contrast humans
evolved as omnivores
we were hunter gatherers that ate both
animal tissue and fibrous plant tissue
our teeth are a mixture of flat and
pointy shapes that were able to tear
raw animal tissue but also crush and
tear plant fibers as well
also dogs cannot chew side to side they
can only chew up and down
aiding in the slicing and cutting of
tissue we humans however can chew both
vertically and horizontally a trait
inherited from omnivores
also if you notice dogs tend to eat
their food fairly quickly despite the
size of their food
just a few quick bites and it's
swallowed dogs evolved to eat quickly
from wolves and can do this because
their saliva glands produce a constant
excessive amount of saliva this explains
why dogs
slobber so much the excessive saliva
lubricates the mouth
esophagus and food so it all slides down
much easier however if the food is too
large to slide down the esophagus the
dog will throw it back up
if you've ever seen this you may have
thought your dog was sick or choking on
their food
nope your pooch is fine this is natural
and is just the dog's body telling it to
chew
a little more however humans cannot do
this because it's called bulimia
speaking of saliva dogs and humans also
have different enzymes in their mouth
for starters dogs have fewer enzymes in
their mouth than humans
this is because in a dog's digestive
system the digestion begins in the
stomach
but for humans digestion begins in the
mouth
salivary enzymes break down complex
macromolecules into simpler molecules
like complex sugar into glucose protein
into amino acids and triglycerides into
glycerides and free fatty acids
these reduced molecules are then further
broken down and digested in the stomach
and since we're on the topic let's talk
about the stomach some people think that
the role of the stomach is to absorb
nutrients into the body
not quite the stomach is where the
chemical breakdown of food happens
the mouth is the physical breakdown from
large portions into small portions
and early chemical breakdown but the
stomach is where serious molecular
breakdown happens into even smaller
molecular portions
the stomach does this by using
hydrochloric acid which is excreted by
parietal cells on the wall
of the stomach on a scale of acid
strength human gastric acid has a
strength of about 2.5 ph
which is very strong for comparison
nitric acid has a ph of 3
and sulfuric acid has a ph of 2.7
however the gastric acid in a dog
stomach has a ph
of 1.8 making it much stronger than a
human's
it takes one half hour for food to move
from the stomach to the intestines in
humans
but for dogs it takes up to 12 hours
again this is an evolutionary mechanism
that dogs inherited from wolves
unlike a human stomach a dog stomach
acts as a storage facility that releases
energy when it is needed
in the wild wolves may go for long
periods of time without eating and adapt
into this evolutionary pressure by
releasing food into the intestines at a
much slower rate
when a dog requires more energy food is
shunted from the stomach to the
intestines much faster nutrients are
absorbed and atp is made for energy
production
finally the intestines the intestines
absorb nutrients from the food
once it's been reduced to individual
molecules intestinal cells have
structures called villi that absorb
nutrients into the blood as the
converted food passes
through the gi tract the longer the
intestine the longer the absorption
takes
for humans our intestines stretch about
25 feet long from start to finish that
is from the beginning of the small
intestine to the rectum takes about
20 to 30 hours total dogs however have
much shorter intestines making their
transit time about six to eight hours
shorter intestinal length is a trait
found among carnivores
in order to have a fast turnover of
energy production to hunt prey
despite dogs being omnivorous they still
maintain a predominant amount of
carnivorous traits
one specific one being a shorter gi
tract a dog's intestine makes up about
25 percent of its total gi tract length
in contrast cats which are true
carnivores only have about 15 percent of
their gi tract consisting of intestines
finally after absorption in the
intestines waste is excreted through the
excretory system
which i can't exactly show for various
reasons
i'll close with this despite humans and
dogs having very different digestive
systems there are foods that dogs can
eat that we eat as well
these foods are watermelon berries
oatmeal
peanut butter cheese eggs and cooked
white rice
however due to lack of enzymes or
difference in digestion time foods that
dogs cannot eat
are grapes onions garlic chocolate and
[Music]
bacon bacon is on here because it's
abnormally high in fat for dogs and has
been known to cause pancreatitis